[Music]
welcome back to my newest discussion
video something that I mentioned
recently on my Facebook and my Twitter
was that I am a huge fan of anime and
right then a lot of people are like oh
he likes that he's one of those guys who
likes that stuff and that made me
realize there actually is something I'd
really like to talk to you guys about
and that is why anime is actually very
important now if you're not a fan of
anime that's cool I mean you don't have
to be a lot of animes can be very cheesy
and very stupid and over stylized but
the great ones can be just as good if
not better than some of our best
live-action movies and I'm going to talk
to you guys about some of my favorite
anime films and television shows about
animes that have influenced American
movies and give you guys a few examples
of anime films or TV shows that you can
watch they can easily get you into anime
but what I want to stress the most in
this video is why I think it should be
watched much more than it is and why I
feel it's underappreciated
amongst film lovers my history with
anime as it did with many people my age
started in middle school with the
Toonami programming block on Cartoon
Network they debuted such shows as
Dragonball Z of course Sailor Moon
outlaw star Tenchi Muyo and the internet
was getting really popular and kids were
starting to get the Internet in all of
their houses and there became this
humongous explosion and knowledge of the
fact that there was all this
entertainment over in Japan that was
really awesome and all of a sudden
everyone wanted to know more about it
they wanted to get more shows imported
over to America it was starting to no
longer become this underground cult
thing that it was in the early 90s in
America because anime was like this
thing where you were like oh you like
anime awesome dude
you're my best friend now because no one
else in this state likes anime just you
and me because of Toonami and it may
became very important to me and it was
something that really meant a lot to me
in my life and I began to seek out other
titles I began to mature in my love for
anime and I watch things like Cowboy
Bebop which in my opinion is one of the
greatest pieces of entertainment ever
created I'm serious if you have not seen
the TV show Cowboy Bebop it is only 26
episodes long that's not because it got
cancelled this is
a very common trend in anime a lot of
animes only run 26 episodes it's just a
thing they do out of any anime I will
recommend that you watch this one if you
want to get into anime because it is
something you can actually do in a
couple days and once you get to episode
5 I dare you to not be interested in
what comes next there are so many anime
films that have really influenced
American entertainment the film Akira
had quite a bit of an influence on films
like The Matrix a film ghost in the
shell' which I do not have with me
currently also humongous influence on
the matrix these are films that are
considered animation classics but your
average movie lover has never seen them
people come up to me all the time and
they say hey have you seen that one
movie and if I say no they flip out they
freak out and they're like you haven't
seen that movie you shouldn't be talking
about movies do you have any idea how
many incredibly awesome and classic
animes I could just do a rebuttal with
instantly and say hey have you seen
ghosts in the show hey have you seen
Acura
oh you haven't well shut up this film
came out in 1988 and it is entirely
hand-drawn if you watch this movie and
realize that men and women holding
pencils and other instruments drew all
of these things that you are
experiencing your mind will explode I
mean I am a good drawer I like to draw
I've drawn a lot of things here's a
couple examples of some of my favorite
drawings that I've made but I have
absolutely no idea how to even imagine
beginning creating a consistently moving
image that way it's mind-blowing a film
that very much inspired one of my
all-time favorite movies inception is an
anime called paprika this was directed
by Satoshi Kon who unfortunately is no
longer with us
this movie is incredibly confusing very
difficult but it is absolutely
enthralling as a mystery suspense film
it's a little hard to follow but the way
this film is directed its constant
visual beauty will make your eyes pop
out of your head another film by status
icon that I love is perfect blue I've
actually done a review of this movie on
my channel under my overlooked review
segment if you want to watch a more
in-depth review about perfect blue I've
already done one this movie is extremely
mature and very Hitchcockian darren
aronofsky actually bought the rights to
perfect blue for $60,000
just so he could recreate an exact scene
from it in requiem for a dream and a lot
of people think that Black Swan is very
much so a remake of perfect blue which
would make sense since he owns the
rights to the movie anime is a genre
that when people hear it they
automatically think two things either
it's a cartoon for kids or you're a nerd
for watching anime at least the majority
of people look and they say it's a
cartoon the genre is filled with so much
mature adult entertainment I'm not
talking about hentai I'm talking about
films that challenge your mind films
that as you watch them can actually
access certain parts of your brain that
a live-action movie can't if you're not
into anime as an art form I understand
that but if you love movies you really
got to give it a try and if you really
want to know some good animes to get
into that are easy to watch that can
kind of get you into the genre strongly
you strongly recommend Cowboy Bebop
check out that anime and of course Hayao
Miyazaki's wonderful works like My
Neighbor Totoro this is a film that all
ages can enjoy it's technically a family
movie but it really is a movie that gets
into the emotion and the spirit of being
a kid and of course the animation is
absolutely breathtaking but my favorite
Hayao Miyazaki movie is actually
Princess Mononoke I strongly recommend
checking out that movie as well it is an
epic fantasy anime and I'm telling you
guys if you're not into anime you are
missing out on something and I want to
start something I'm gonna make an
announcement here I would like to
regularly review anime new television
shows new anime films that are coming
out I want to do my best to be able to
do that starting with attack on Titan
which I picked up recently this is going
to be reviewed sometime in September
because part two of the blu-ray comes
out then I want to start talking more
about anime on this channel I want to
have a regular anime review segment on
this channel and I'm gonna do my best to
keep up with that guys if your movie
lovers and I'm pretty sure most of you
are give anime a try in my opinion I
preferred over American animation that's
the honest truth I really hope you guys
check out some of the things I've
recommended and as always guys thank you
so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck
moist
[Music]